[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies einen schönen guten
abend wünsche ich ihnen alles wichtige
vom sport von kawak leben ein stück von
mir hier auf schauen wir heute besonders
pläne zur quarantäne regeln raus dürfen
das sollen beschäftigte bestimmte berufe
schon nach fünf tagen schlägt der
gesundheitsminister vor
ein herz und lunge schwächer werden laut
einer studie können selbst leichte kost
erkrankungen zu organschäden führen
und vor entscheidungen bei der
vierschanzentournee der japaner
kobayashi gewinnt auch in bischofshofen
karl geiger wird vierter
kurz vor dem entscheidenden
bund-länder-treffen am freitag wird
konkreter wie und für wen die quarantäne
verkürzt werden soll so gab es dazu
heute eine einigung des
bundesgesundheitsministers mit seinen
kolleginnen und kollegen aus den ländern
lauterbach will auch die kontakte weiter
beschränken er geht davon aus dass in
wenigen tagen in deutschland omikron die
dominierende virusvariante sein wird
christoph des 3 berichtet
bremen war mal die nummer eins beim
impfen hat er das virus im griff vorbei
jetzt müssen sie sich im büro für fall
nachverfolgung mit omikron rumschlagen
haben soviel infizierte wie nie gerade
weil man so früh so konsequent war wir
haben hier in bremen sehr schnell
geimpft und viele menschen erreicht das
war in der mitte des jahres und jetzt
sind natürlich viele monate vergangen
das heißt der schutz vor der infektion
mit omikron ist jetzt tatsächlich
relativ niedrig jetzt geht es um so
boostern doch die omikron welle schwappt
ja bereits hoch zu viele kranke und
isolierte könnte das auf einmal geben
wird befürchtet der plan also quarantäne
regeln lockern in das öffentliche leben
am laufen zu halten dazu hat
gesundheitsminister lauterbach mit dem
rk ii ein konzept erarbeitet und heute
den landesgesundheitsminister
vorgestellt daraus wurden in einer
gemeinsamen video schalte wie es heißt
ganz praktische vorschläge fürs
bevorstehende bund länder treffen wenn
etwa zweifach geimpfte bei polizei oder
feuerwehr das neue virus bekommen kann
die isolation also von diejenigen die
sich infiziert haben zum zwecke der
arbeitsaufnahme bereits nach tagen
mittels negativen pcr test beendet
werden dann der kritische bereich schule
darüber haben heute die kultusminister
geredet neue quarantäne regeln halten
auch sie für eine gute idee oberste
priorität aber habe die
schulschließungen unbedingt vermeiden
denn
auch recht erhaltung der schulbetrieb
ist regisseurin relevant für kinder und
jugendliche aber eben auch weil
andere bereiche die kritische
infrastruktur zur aufrechterhaltung
ihrer arbeitsfähigkeit hiervon abhängig
sind
omikron trifft kritische infrastruktur
was es genau braucht um sie zu schützen
übermorgen also wollen bund und länder
dazu entscheidungen treffen
bei den corona zahlen setzt sich der
steigende trend fort das robert koch
institut meldet 58 1912 neuinfektionen
das sind 18
1869 mehr als vor einer woche
346 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidents
liegt bei 200 58,6 und auch die zahl der
nachgewiesenen omikron fälle wächst auf
insgesamt
42.500 56 das sind 20 prozent mehr als
am vortag
welche schweren folgen eine krone
erkrankung haben kann zeigt eine neue
studie des universitätsklinikums hamburg
eppendorf
selbst wenn die krankheit nur milde
verläuft kann es zu schäden an herz
lunge und nieren kommen das scheint
besonders bedeutsam angesichts von
omikron wo die symptome oftmals milder
zu sein scheinen martin neeson mit den
einzelheiten
eva ego infizierte sich bevor in
deutschland geimpft wurde der verlauf
war eher mild und trotzdem leidet sie
seit über einem jahr an wiederkehrender
atemnot mein herz ist in ordnung meine
lunge ist in ordnung
neurologisch ist alles in ordnung
psychologisch aber
man weiß nicht woher die atemnot kommt
zu langzeit folgen hat das uniklinikum
hamburg eppendorf heute eine studie
veröffentlicht dafür wurden 443
ungeimpfte menschen im alter zwischen 5
40 und 74 jahren nach überstandener saß
kauf zwei infektion eingehend untersucht
die ergebnisse zeigen dass zu einem
minimalen effekt dass die herzleistung
beeinträchtigt ist die lungenfunktion
beeinträchtigt es die nieren leistung
etwas reduziert ist und der deutlichste
effekt war in zeichen von stadt gehabten
beiden venenthrombosen zu sehen
langfristig können aus diesem geringen
beeinträchtigungen aber auch eine
herzinsuffizienz oder eine lungenembolie
entstehen der studienleiter rät vor
allem ungeimpften deswegen zu
kontrolluntersuchungen
nach durchgemachter corona infektion
ungefähr sechs bis neun monate danach
empfehlen wir zwei blutuntersuchungen
ihren wert messen herzfunktion wert
messen und dann in einer zweiten stufe
sollten auffälligkeiten sein ultraschall
vom herzen ultraschall von den beiden
bühnen lungenfunktionstest um machen und
dann weiß man sehr genau bescheid
entsprechende therapien könnten
schwerwiegende folgen dann verhindern
oder zumindest abmildern und
die vierte corona welle hat auch das
vereinigte königreich fest im griff dort
dominiert bereits die omikron variante
in england macht sie inzwischen mehr als
90 prozent der fälle aus denn eines
tages wurden in großbritannien und
nordirland fast
195.000 kroner neuinfektionen
registriert
zu wenig personal und
versorgungsengpässe belasten die
kliniken die ersten rufen nun den
katastrophenfall aus diana zimmermann
ja auch in großbritannien gibt es im
gegner wenn auch nicht sehr viele
vielleicht auch weil alle wissen wie
angespannt die lage in den
krankenhäusern ist momentan ist jeder
zehnte mitarbeiter des
gesundheitssystems krank oder in
isolation dutzende kliniken haben den
katastrophenfall ausgerufen im südwesten
warten patienten mit herzinfarkt oder
schlaganfall im schnitt 74 minuten auf
eine ambulanz
was wir im britischen gesundheitssystem
sehen ist dass die leute jetzt an
anderen dingen sterben als an co wird
die krankenhäuser stehen so unter druck
dass die krankenwagen die patienten gar
nicht abladen können die menschen werden
nicht mehr richtig versorgt
im kampf gegen den personalmangel auch
in schulen und verkehrsbetrieben hat die
regierung die regeln für infizierte ohne
symptome gelockert sie müssen nur noch
schnelltests machen und können zweifach
negativ getestet schon nach sieben tagen
wieder arbeiten omikron gehört zwar zu
den infektionen wären der
menschheitsgeschichte der
krankheitsverlauf scheint aber gerade
unter jungen geimpften selten bedrohlich
zu sein
infektionen und hospitalisierungen
stiegen in großbritannien in der
vergangenen woche um rund 50 prozent die
zahl der toten aber ging ein wenig
zurück der premier will daher die
aktuelle welle einfach aussetzen
wir können als land und gesellschaft
nicht ewig mit lok downs agieren ich
vertraue darauf dass wir diese omikron
welle mit unseren bereits vorhandenen
sehr ausgewogenen maßnahmen durchstehen
können
dass die erkrankungen hier bislang eher
glimpflich verlaufen liegt nach ersten
erkenntnissen daran dass die zahl der
folge impften erwachsenen sehr hoch ist
88 prozent der briten über 18 haben zwei
impfungen 65 prozent sogar den booster
frankreichs präsident makro hat mit
aussagen zu mehr druck auf ungeimpfte
über parteigrenzen hinweg einen sturm
der entrüstung ausgelöst er hatte der
zeitung le parisien übersetzt unter
anderem gesagt er habe große lust die
ungeimpften bis zum bitteren ende so
richtig zu nerven im parlament
überschatteten die äußerungen eine
ohnehin emotional stark aufgeladene
debatte über eine geplante verschärfung
der chor ohne regeln die sitzung musste
abgebrochen werden
in die usa genauer gesagt nach
washington denn hierher führt annalena
baerbock ihre erste reise als
außenministerin außerhalb europas der
besuch bei ihrem us amtskollegen blinken
sei ein zeichen für die enge
transatlantische partnerschaft betonte
baerbock im mittelpunkt der gespräche
standen der ukraine konflikt und das
angespannte verhältnis zu russland
und das treffen hat unsere kollegin
claudia betzin washington beobachtet
claudia ziehen die usa und europa denn
da wirklich an einem strang bei diesem
team
also zunächst mal lassen die beiden
außen die außenministerin und der
außenminister das so erscheinen die
pressekonferenz begann mit einem
überschwang an freundlichen worten und
natürlich haben beide die große
bedeutung der transatlantischen
partnerschaft herausgestellt und das
auch am beispiel des der ukraine krise
durchaus dargelegt dort war die rede von
deeskalation und natürlich auch von
einem hohen preis den putin zu zahlen
hätte wenn er in die ukraine
einmarschieren würde wie außenminister
blinken das sagte massive konsequenzen
von denen er sprach und ministerin
baerbock sagte das russische handeln
gegen der über ukraine sei mit einem
klaren preisschild gekennzeichnet und
bei diesem preisschild da hört dann die
einigkeit möglicherweise eben schon auf
den für die amerikaner steht auf diesem
preisschild auch sanktionen gegen
beteiligte an nordstream zwei an der
nord stream pipeline die hier für einen
großen fehler gehalten wird und da
warten die amerikaner noch darauf dass
die deutsche regierung mit einer stimme
spricht auch bei anderen wesentlichen
punkten internationaler politik die
man sich noch nicht ganz klar wieder die
die positionen zusammenkommen können bei
china zum beispiel das ist für die usa
der grösste geopolitische gegner und für
deutschland das wichtigste der
wichtigste handelspartner
nun erwartet präsident biden dass man
als demokratische nationen dort eine
gemeinsame strategie bauen kann auch mit
den deutschen an seiner seite gegen
china das heißt mittelfristig wird das
deutsche us verhältnis auch davon
abhängen wie sich deutschland bei diesen
wichtigen punkten härter gegen russland
härter gegen china
positionieren wird danke für diese
einschätzung claudia bates
steigende treibstoffpreise haben das
autoritär geführte kasachstan in eine
krise gestürzt nach heftigen
massenprotesten bis die regierung des
zentralasiatischen staates
zurückgetreten
in teilen des landes gilt der
ausnahmezustand
und trotzdem gehen die unruhen weiter es
soll tote und verletzte gegeben haben
schon am wochenende waren tausende auf
die straßen gegangen auch aus wut über
das starke gefälle zwischen arm und
reich axel sturm
längst schon geht es nicht mehr nur um
die gestiegenen preise für flüssiggas in
kasachstan es geht um ihre zukunft sagen
sie und sind bereit dafür gewalt
anzuwenden die reaktion des staates
absehbar es gibt massive angriffe auf
polizisten in unserer geliebten stadt
einige von ihnen wurden getötet oder
verwundet all das kann nicht toleriert
werde die wut scheint keine grenzen zu
kennen inzwischen gilt der
ausnahmezustand das internet an vielen
orten gekappt sie haben die alten
machthaber im visier besonders nursultan
nasarbajew der das land 30 jahre lang
regiert hat und heute noch aus dem
hintergrund die strippen zieht
nasarbajew seine familie sein gefolge
sie schufen diese verteilungs wirtschaft
zugunsten der elite und deshalb sind die
normalen leute die verlierer obwohl sie
offiziell unabhängig wurden
aber es scheint die normalen leute
begehren auf in kasachstan die regierung
ist bereits zurückgetreten präsident
obama braucht damit die lage zu
beruhigen
nach deutschland nach den ampel parteien
unterstützt jetzt auch die union eine
zweite amtszeit von bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier ihren
mitgliedern in der bundesversammlung im
fahlen cdu und cds zur heute steinmeier
am 13 februar wieder zu wählen allein
schon mit den stimmen von spd fdp und
grünen hat steinmeier die erforderliche
mehrheit fünf weitere jahre im schloss
bellevue sind dem 66 jährigen damit
praktisch sicher
tausende krone im zertifikate sind
bereits gefälscht worden und das sind
nur die offiziellen zahlen der jüngste
prominente fall bremens ex trainer
markus anfang hat jetzt zugegeben einen
gefälschten impfpass genutzt zu haben
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
deswegen bereits seit längerem gegen ihn
wie beim fälschen der zertifikate
vorgegangen wird seit ihnen susanne
santina
matthias gronkiewicz ist schon vor
längerer zeit aufgefallen dass bei ihm
in bad homburg immer mehr stempel von
angeblichen impfzentren und ärzten
bestellt wurden der versand aber an
privatleute ging das machte ihn
misstrauisch und er erstattete bei der
polizei anzeige
erfolglos schließlich haben wir dann
sogar direkt ins gesundheitsministerium
geschrieben ans justizministerium und
von dort aus wurde uns mehr oder weniger
mitgeteilt dass wir diese
benachrichtigung unterlassen sollten
fest steht gefälschte impfpässe werden
zum massenphänomen
mehr als 11.000 fälle sind den
landeskriminalämtern mittlerweile
bekannt und die dunkelziffer ist hoch
ein telegramm kanälen wie diesen werden
bis heute gefälschte impfpässe angeboten
meistens unter falschem namen telegramm
selbst hilft den ermittlern bei der
entfernung bislang nicht das bundesamt
für justiz ist da hinterher die zum
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz zu treiben
aber ist es ein harter weg
auch apothekerin einer schirmer wird
immer wieder mit fälschungs versuchen
bei impfpässe konfrontiert sie hat einen
ordner angelegt und früh festgestellt
dass stempel und aufkleber im impfpass
viel zu leicht zu fälschen sind mögliche
fälschungen aufzudecken findet sie
wichtig
aber dass wir natürlich noch
kriminalistisch tätig werden müssen ist
eine frechheit eigentlich müsste genau
der der die impfung durchführt auch das
digitale zertifikat ausstellen auch
matthias gronkiewicz hält das für den
richtigen weg er selbst verweigert eine
stempel auslieferung wenn er den
verdacht hat dass ein impfpass gefälscht
werden soll
schauen wir nun in den ganz hohen norden
in die arktis wo die folgen der
erderwärmung deutlich zu beobachten sind
das schmelzen von gletschern am packeis
macht seltener bodenschätze in enormen
ausmass zugänglich und längst hat die
ausbeutung dieser bislang unberührte
naturräume begonnen unser reporter
johannes hano hat sich auf die reise ins
wohl nicht mehr ganz so ewige eis
begeben sein bericht beginnt in
spitzbergen
wir sind unterwegs durch eine region die
bis vor kurzem noch rationen bezwingbar
kalt heute aber ist ein wettlauf
ausgebrochen darum wenn sie in zukunft
dominiert wir haben eine rolle wo mit
der norwegischen fregatte thor heyerdahl
im xj auf spitzbergen den vergangenen
jahren schickt norwegen seine
kriegsschiffe immer häufiger hoch in den
norden in die arktische sehen sie suchen
hier regelmäßig nach oben
im vergangenen jahr haben wir verstärkt
russische aktivität festgestellt sie
sind hier öfter unterwegs und fahren
auch in andere regionen weiter westlich
und entlang der norwegischen küste
russland setzt neue schwerpunkte baut
seine präsenz in der arktis massiv aus
und lässt es alle wissen am nordpol
brechen vergangenes jahr unbemerkt drei
atom-u-boote durchs eis potenzielle
kontrahenten sollen sich darüber im
klaren sein wozu russland in der lage
ist wer die arktis dominiert da für
russland ist der ferne osten und die
arktis strategisch bedeutend
russland ist in diesen regionen
wirtschaftlich sehr aktiv von neuen
steht mit mehr als 100000 einwohnern
sind sechs in russland
russlands nachbarn in der arktis aber
werden unruhig
sie werden aktiv und das ist nicht
verboten aber es wirkt aggressiv und wie
gesagt sie sind agiler schneller so
haben wir weniger zeit uns darauf
einzustellen und zu reagieren
norwegen wünscht sich mehr
aufmerksamkeit der nato für die arktis
einer region die sich in einer
dramatischen geschwindigkeit verändert
und heute abend um 22 uhr 10 können sie
die gesamte doku aktiv blue machtpoker
im schmelzenden eis bei uns im zdf sehen
oder schon jetzt in unserer mediathek
und jetzt kommen wir zur
vierschanzentournee robert
mein gott ist auch in china aber robert
auch bischofshofen der dritte wettbewerb
und danach haben die deutschen
skispringer keine hoffnung mehr auf den
gesamtsieg bester deutscher heute karl
geiger als vierte
gewonnen hat erneut der japanische
seriensieger rio kobayashi markus
eisenbichler dagegen bleibt nur applaus
für die konkurrenz nach verpatztem
ersten sprung so ruht die hoffnung des
deutschen teams auf einen podestplatz
allein auf karl geiger der sechste der
gesamtwertung und führte nach dem ersten
sprung mit einem schönen flug auf 136
meter verbessern aber kann er sich damit
nicht
das war heute echt gut und ich bin
gewohnt nervenstark und technisch
brillant einmal mehr der tournee sieger
des vorjahres kobayashi mit
137,5 metern verdrängte japaner den nach
dem ersten sprung führenden norweger
lind weg noch auf rang zwei in der
gesamtwertung baute seine führung von
entwickler aus auf 4 der tagesachter
eisenbichler karl geiger knapp dahinter
auf 5
wirbel um novak djokovic der offenbar
ungeimpfte serbische tennis da wollte
heute mit einer medizinischen
sondergenehmigung zu den austrian open
einreisen aber am flughafen melbourne
erklärten die behörden sein visum
zunächst für ungültig um 14 uhr
deutscher zeit ist novak djokovic am
flughafen in melbourne gelandet und saß
zunächst fest dabei hatte der neunmalige
australian-open-sieger gestern noch
erklärt dass für seine einreise eine
medizinische ausnahmegenehmigung
vorliegt der australische
premierminister sagte dazu wir warten
darauf wie er seinen antrag belegt wenn
der nachweis unzureichend ist wird er am
nächsten flieger nach hause sitzen den
australien wurden in der pandemie
flugreisen immer wieder untersagt sie
waren von ihren kindern getrennt oder
konnten sterbende angehörige nicht
begleiten die stimmung ist aufgeheizt
wir tun hier einfach alles lassen uns
impfen boostern und dann kommt er
einfach aus übersee
mittlerweile soll djokovic die einreise
gewährt worden seien da sich die
grenzbehörden des landes über die
behörden victorias hinweggesetzt hätten
das was uns gut danke norbert das
goldfische nicht zu den aller cleversten
tieren gehören dieser mythos hält sich
hartnäckig
in wahrheit haben sie mehr drauf als man
denkt zum beispiel autofahren kein witz
sondern ein experiment durchgeführt an
der ben gurion universität in israel
forschende haben ein aquarium auf räder
gepackt und das pferd wohin der fisch
schwimmt richtung belohnung
welche lottozahlen wurden gezogen das
erfahren sie jetzt die gewinnzahlen
lauten 24 67 32 41 und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
heute nacht gibt es noch einige schnee
regen und schneeschauer es wird glatt
auf den straßen für morgen kündigt katja
horne vergleich ruhigeres wetter an das
heute-journal können sie um 21 40 sehen
mit marietta slomka auf wiedersehen
[Musik]